hello guys it's me nikki
hi
adele gets glammed by youtuber nikki
tutorials i felt the need because i love
her the superstar sits down with the
beauty guru for a power of makeup
session where she gets revealing about
music makeup and movie stars someone
i've never met
that i think i would actually cry
who
is the rock yep that's adele fangirling
over dwayne johnson it was amazing and
it turns out the feeling is mutual he
sent me flowers the other day because
him and his wife couldn't make my show
literally only fell off my chair to be
clear adele says it's not a crush oh
yeah it's not like i'm not going to
crash or anything it's just like no he's
amazing be my father he's just
incredible this wouldn't be my mate next
up the icon spills some beauty secrets
i'm not great at my makeup i can't do a
line love a brow okay good but also if i
don't dye my brows like these are dyed
okay like they i look i look like
voldemort
that's definitely me that was all right
as for her new album 30 adele revealed
the song i drink wine is getting a music
video the music video we shot a while
ago but it's just
hilarious i mean it's the campus thing
you'll ever see
and i feel like everyone might be
dressed up as halloween for it next year
and speaking of wine cheers babes i'm
30. cheers the grammy winner breaks her
own rules as she sips on some oh my god
you did i can't bloody drink at the
moment
cause i'm working
do you know okay i'll have a little
glass yes later the songstress gets deep
as she opens up about the pressure of
fame and her habit of taking a break
from the spotlight the more success you
come into
you know the more
everything else sort of falls apart you
know it's hard to really get a balance
and it's quite terrifying sometimes
living those things out in public how do
you
well i'm in recluse babes i disappear
for five or six years at a time
but for now adele is back and fans are
loving it in october her first instagram
live nearly broke the internet i've
never done this before
she then went on to deliver an epic cbs
concert special and interview with oprah
winfrey by the way adele said her and
her boyfriend rich paul had a hard time
keeping their cool around the media
queen
it was so
normal right and then but every now and
then we catch ourselves being all stuff
like it's an oprah
you